how that kind of happens is the fact
that when a parent and Rob with someone
that woman would often weaken him down
into that position and I know you read
about that too in terms of like turning
a semi-alpha dude into a beta male as a
result
why is that conditioning happening
because I have several examples of
people that I've seen that happen to but
how does that happen I can how does that
happen over time I guess yeah the
process is called betatization through a
thousand concessions is a way that I
would Define it and that's just a guy
agreeing to uh subsequent concessions
over a long period of time and it starts
with something light you know like when
she says hey let's move in together and
he lives his life a certain way and
she's like well I don't like that the
socks are in that one basket let's have
a dark hamper for dark clothes and a
white hamper for light clothes so if you
could please organize you know your
socks and not leave them on the floor
and put them in the hamper and then this
is when a guy slowly starts to make some
slow changes to his life to accommodate
her and women generally look at that go
well that's not wrong rich like that
just makes sense that's just a better
way to organize stuff right you're right
it probably is a better way to organize
things but if he's lived that way and
he's 30 years old and he's been living
that way for the last 10 years that's
one concession that he's made then it
goes to the next concession and the next
and they pile up and it and it goes from
her looking at this guy as a strong
virtuous man that she once looked up to
that she admired that she had in
enthusiastic orgasmic sex with to this
guy five years down the road through
five years of concessions small
concessions that added up over time he's
basically now her little [__] you know
she like she ends up pussifying the man
and it's not like she does this
intentionally like women don't get up in
the morning and say right I have to get
up and pussify this [__] you
know sort of thing like this isn't how
women operate but it's them trying to
make sure everything is orderly within
the nest right and it's incumbent upon
men to set boundaries and be firm with
those boundaries and not you know yield
to all these little tests and
concessions that are being required of
them
um I'll give an example I you know I
take a lot of supplements I have a
supplement line obviously you know if
you guys have followed my channel and I
just keep my pill bottles out on my
counter in my kitchen and my girlfriend
hates it she's like you know why can't
we put them away why can't we put them
in a tray can we put them in a lazy
Susan I'm like no
that's that's where they are it's
convenient for me they're not moving I
have them out so I know that I have to
take them and I can easily see which
ones I have to take and that's it end of
story right but the vast majority of men
will be like okay you know what do you
want to do you want to put in a lazy
Susan whatever you want babe right and
it's like okay like that's not going to
dry her up she's not going to hate you
because of that but if you do that 50
times 100 times 300 times with small
concessions here and there all of a
sudden she's gonna get up one day and
look at you and be like [__] this guy's
a [__] yeah and the guy is going to
take less risk overall so I think on a
microscope it's softer exactly exactly
so I know microscale that works really
well but for me this dials into so much
different aspects so we went back to the
physical the the mental or like let's
say the pursuit of siblings and when we
get older it's usually like a business
that's in pursuit of it feels like that
when I look people who are older than me
they've closed themselves into this
perspective so that they don't take the
risk you don't ever want to go and
pursue something they fall out of their
health and fitness they blame it on
actually having a child people might
have some you know people like oh I'm
having a kid I can't I can't go to the
gym anymore and then there's one
interesting things that happens to men
when they have a family where they have
children is their testosterone number
drop
because it's just more of a female like
environment it's well you know there's
there's
experts that suggest that it happens so
that men don't run off and that they
stay with the child to raise and protect
the child because men are more apt to
have more promiscuous sex with a bunch
of women if they have super high
testosterone right so one of the things
that happens you know when the children
come along is his testosterone levels
drop which is why he gets less
aggressive uh you know he may Chase less
Excellence he may be less interested in
going to the gym or maintaining Combat
Sports that's when he starts to put like
there's the dad bod there's no 20 year
old Bob there's no teen bot there's only
dad bods right 100 so it's one of those
interesting things that that happens
from an evolutionary you know
perspective and you know I would even
argue part of the reasons why immense
testosterone level drops when he gets in
a long-term relationship and has a
family and gets married and all that too
is because he goes through that
betaization through a thousand
concessions you can't be a strong
virtuous man that that runs a uh a
family you know you know his uh you know
his life and and he leads it if he's
constantly saying yes yes yes yes yes
yes to every little thing that she wants
him to do
that's crazy I I it's like you know
you've got a penny drops not a fact
because it's like
it's almost like an excuse you do it and
it's an excuse now he's fat lazy low
tests and just very easy to fall over as
a result and not necessarily uh still
have that pursuit of things and I don't
know it's something to be very mindful
of as I'm getting a little bit older but
it's funny because as I've as I've as
I've gotten older my test has actually
increased would you believe I was I had
a podcast recently where I actually went
through it when I went a guy because I
don't drink alcohol I have a very strict
diet I have a coach I'm in Sun you know
I'm always out my my health is my life
is more driven towards Health than in
the business than it is towards slowing
down because I think you know similar
enough personality type is that my
biggest fear I don't know how you feel
about this is that of of slowing down I
I don't want to be someone who slows
down whether physically or mentally
um because it's not just a shame that
you don't live up to the potential you
can go and do there's only two states in
life I believe and it's growing or dying
you can't stand still so you have to
lean into growth I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out